♪ (INTENSE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Everyone thinks anarchy is,
uh... "do whatever you want."
SPEAKER: Anarchy just means
self-ownership.
The most peaceful ideology
in the world.
SPEAKER 2: The state
has oppressed me since birth.
SPEAKER 3: I was wanting
more freedom
and wanting to be
controlled less.
SPEAKER 4: We wanted a pure
anarchist life for our kids.
SPEAKER 2: What they did
in Mexico was a solution.
SPEAKER 4: What would you think
about a conference in Mexico?
People just like you and I,
who question authority,
who wanna live differently
in Acapulco.
SPEAKER 5:
It will change your life.
No, we don't want
anarchist people here.
It's going to be fucking epic.
ALL: (CONSECUTIVELY)
Anarchapulco.
SPEAKER 6: The biggest
anarchist conference.
A trip to Mexico,
I'm really excited.
SPEAKER 7:
The world is waking up.
-My best friends are anarchists!
-Fuck the government.
(BOOING)
SPEAKER 8: Most of our people
were buying into Bitcoin.
Coming in on private jets
and yachts.
-(CASH REGISTER DINGS)
-(HOWLS)
Wu-Tang Clan is here.
SPEAKER 4:
This beautiful paradise
can be a beacon of freedom
for people to migrate to.
And then...
the murder happened.
REPORTER: An anarchist
has been shot to death.
REPORTER 2:
A tragic situation...
There was some sketchy stuff
happening behind the scenes.
You need to stop
or there's going to be
serious consequences.
-(SIREN WAILING)
-You listen, or you die.
SPEAKER 2: I heard,
"Bang, bang, bang."
SPEAKER 9: I'm scared
out of my mind.
SPEAKER 10: There was
a legitimate fear
that there's a bomb
at the conference.
At which point we were like,
"What the fuck?"
REPORTER 3: Crypto crash.
We were struggling.
We were all pretty desperate.
SPEAKER 10:
It's amazing how destructive
human beings can be
if they decide to not cooperate
and play nice.
SPEAKER 2: There's a lot
of bloodshed in this city,
just all over the place.
This is real anarchy here.
This is not okay.
Not okay at all.
SPEAKER 11: They are
going to come after us.
We have to be strong.
SPEAKER 12: Is there
a limit to the sacrifice that
you're willing to make...
-(SOBS)
-No, no, no, no, no, no!
...to fix the broken world?
JEFF BERWICK:
The blood is in the streets.
What are you gonna do?
♪ (MUSIC CLIMAXES) ♪
-Are we strong?
-(CROWD CHEERS)